hey guys good morning I just woke up and
I've been having this reoccurring
nightmare and you can definitely tell
it's the morning because the Sun is
right here in my eyes so the nightmare
starts like this
I wake up I look at my phone and I
realized that I have overslept and I've
missed the entire Apple announcement but
the worst part about it is that I got an
invite this is all theoretical in my
dream and since I got an invite I wake
up in my own bed realizing that I have
completely missed my flight I've missed
the announcement and my whole first
world problems come crashing down might
not seem like a nightmare to some of you
but every morning I keep waking up in a
panic what you just saw in this entire
rest of this video after this little
clip before we had the official release
date and the official release date right
here at the special event Steve Jobs
theater September 12 10:00 a.m. it's so
crazy that I woke up this morning with
this premonition that this was gonna
happen the invites have officially been
sent down will still be glued to the
screen so it looks like all of the
rumors and premonitions and leaks and
everything else is true it's October
12th today 10:00 a.m. which means we are
that much closer to a new iPhone iPhones
there's gonna be multiple
anyway let's continue on with this video
that I shot and edited before this
announcement so then I had to make a few
changes here at the beginning let's
carry on but today I just wanted to chat
with you guys pretty quickly because it
has been not officially announced but
unofficially officially leaked September
12th will be the date of the actual
Apple announcement usually if the Apple
announcement is a little bit earlier in
September which I was kind of hoping for
because I'm gonna be traveling the end
of the month which would put the date of
the iPhone being released
something happens every single time the
iPhone comes out like last time do you
guys remember I order the jet black
wherever the jet black it was like four
or five days late and then on the 6s I
feel like something happened and then
the six I had to sleep outside and at
one point I got an empty box for the
iPhone 4 you know I just think for the
iPhone guys they're not on my side
sometimes so I'm looking in my iCal so
September 12th if that's the actual date
of the announcement usually Apple will
release the phone a week later that next
Friday so looking here that would put
the release date at about the 22nd which
is pretty crazy because that's really
really soon there's also been a lot of
speculation on whether or not the iPhone
8 will actually be released that day
there's been so many reports of delays
because the OLED screen and a facial
recognition and before most people
thought it was because they were trying
to get the touch ID to work integrated
into the phone but now that's pretty
much non-existent almost everything that
I've read it's pretty much confirmed
that there will not be a touch ID at all
it will all be facial recognition which
kind of makes me a little bit nervous
because that's something that Apple has
not done before so with that being said
fingers crossed that there's no issues
everything works perfectly with most
things Daewon products there's usually
some issues so let's just hope that
doesn't happen with the touch ID being
removed that's gonna put some
complications on how you actually use
your phone because one of the things
that you're used to doing is pressing
this button to go home it unlocks your
phone it does basically everything to
get you back to where you need to be so
here's a really cool animation from Mac
rumors that they have from this guy
right here showing you what it would be
like to use your phone without the touch
ID it'll all be using gesture controls
which I feel like could get a little bit
confusing for people who are so used to
iOS and how it usually functions but for
most people that I think you're pretty
tech savvy I think we'll be okay I'm
pretty sure this gesture is something I
can handle it
may I but look how good this looks it
does look a lot like an essay I will say
that I really like these images is well
that shows what the status bar can look
like so because the new iPad does have
this dock or haven't seen this yet in
the iOS 11 beta the current version of
iOS 11
that I'm using is beta eight and it's
been working really really well
beta 5 was super rough you just can drag
the gesture bar up to the middle of the
screen to unlock the device when inside
an app a similar gesture starts
multitasking and continues to flick
upwards to close the app and go back to
the home screen it's gonna be really
weird using your phone without having
that physical button or somewhere that
you're used to pressing I'm excited to
test that out something that I am
excited about is the new increase in
storage it's said that there's gonna be
a 512 gig of the iPhone 8 which will put
all of the sides the no 64 256 and 512
with three gigs of ram it's so crazy to
think about how much technology is in
your phone when I was asking my parents
for 32 megabytes of RAM when I was in
middle school for Christmas it kind of
crazy to think too that the lowest
amount of storage is 64 gigs a lot of
people store things on the cloud so you
don't necessarily need to have a largest
phone but for me I put a lot of 4k
videos on my phone not just necessarily
the ones that I take from my camera but
I usually send the YouTube videos that I
make here on my computer to my phone and
I use different apps to make little gifs
and then sometimes I like to post them
on Instagram and post them on Facebook
from my phone so not only do I have all
of the videos that have actually shot
using this camera I have almost all of
the videos that I've filmed and shot and
I post on YouTube those 4k video files
definitely add up on average each file
is at least a gig so 512 that's gonna go
really quick well it looks like the
iPhone 8 interface is going to be ugly
okay is that clearly this is the
headline looking for clicks and
controversy which I don't 100% disagree
with what's that talking about here in
this article is the notch that is cut
out of the iPhone 8 how developers and
Apple decides to handle that I'm not
sure what its gonna look like because
this version of iOS 11 is not on an
iPhone 8 so I'm not really sure
the hideous way to approach the new
display design is to have a big notch
cut above the top of act
this is apparently the option Apple has
decided to go with I don't really think
it's gonna be that bad I feel like they
won't really know until we actually see
the phone we get it in our hands and get
to decide for ourselves but calling it
ugly and hideous I think is a little bit
far I think it's gonna be perfectly fine
and no one's even gonna notice and if
they do notice I'll print out my words
and I will eat them so here you can see
what he was talking about with the notch
cut out if you made this part black
right here it would all blend in very
nicely but it will be interesting to see
how different apps kind of take
advantage of that because when you are
on your phone and you open up a
different app that whole top area still
stays there but it does change depending
upon which app you're opening so I'm
assuming that's something that
developers will have to decide I don't
know I'm unsure I don't have all the
answers I wish I did I probably won't
even have a phone day one this looks
nice no notch cut out it looks beautiful
this is something I can get behind how
does that look ugly it doesn't it's
beautiful people briefed on the product
pricing from $9.99 350 and price
increasing that's that is a pretty
significant price increase but here is
another thing that I am also thinking if
you are an obsessive phone user and you
basically are running your entire life
off of your phone I hardly even use my
computer anymore unless I'm editing I do
everything on here well what exactly are
we getting extra for that 350 we'll find
out and last but not least is this color
one of my favorite colors is almost this
color it's pretty similar I'm so jhanas
it's almost very similar to that I don't
even know if my color correcting is
gonna be accurate I can absolutely love
this color of the rose gold I felt like
this was beautiful it's almost like a
darker color of the rose gold I guess
they're calling it a blush copper pink
even though I'm not super into this
color I feel like for some reason I'm
probably gonna really like it in person
maybe this color is a little bit off I'm
hoping it's a little bit off because I
feel like it's a little bit too dark
with a color
how many days until September 12 twelve
days on the first day of iphone miss my
Syria came to me hey Siri is there
anything happening on September 12th
here's what I found on the web first
there anything happening on September 12
when is the new iPhone 8 coming out
apple.com should be able to answer that
question and more so at this point we're
a mere 12 days away from the day that we
finally find out about the iPhone 8 and
you know what's absolutely insane I went
to MacRumors this morning they're
already talking about the iPhone 9 but
the newly fixin happens display that
says old iPhone 9 would have an even
largest screen that the Galaxy Note 8
introduced earlier this month the five
point eight five inch version would
likely be the same size the iPhone 8 oh
my gosh we're already talking about the
iPhone 9 I'm ready and we don't even
have an iPhone 7s yet we don't even have
an iPhone eight and we're already
talking about the iPhone 9 do you guys
think that the iPhone eight will
actually be called something else I have
this feeling that it's going to be
called something else but then that
might complicate things and then people
might get confused I don't know what do
you think leave me some comments below
and let me know what you guys think
about the new iPhone 8 do you think it
will be called something else when you
think about the iPhone 9 at this point
if the iPhone 8 is called something else
then they can't call the iPhone on the
iPhone 9 I'm stressed out well thank you
guys so much for watching I'm gonna
leave you with one last thing I'm gonna
put some links in the description where
you guys can donate to help hurricane
Harvey victims it's been absolutely
devastating to see what has happened in
these cities and people losing their
homes and their lives and their pets and
everything that they own and the little
bits that we can help will definitely
help and go a long way so many people
have donated so much time and effort and
energy and money into this cause that
hopefully everyone affected will soon
find their way and be able to get back
on their feet again so to all of you
guys affected your friends or family I
love you and if you haven't donated
already anything will help but IRA see
you guys later
[Music]